it's getting really good it's getting
really good now you know about anyone
who knows anything about Barry Allen
knows that he's always late but then
when he arrives he gets stuff done and
that's definitely how this film's
production schedule was proceeding yeah
we're a little light but we're really
you know the reason why we're late and
this is the honest-to-god truth is the
reason why we're late is because we're
all and I include myself in this we are
very meticulously focused on making a
movie that's not just like one of the
greatest superhero movies that we can
possibly make this movie is also gonna
be a gift to the fans you know this
movie this movie's gonna be a real pure
offering to the fans of this material
and we've hit a couple points in the
scripts development where we've looked
at it and gone mmm this isn't it this
isn't it yet it has to be and you know
we're really we're starting about we're
talking about sparking a whole new
universe which is it's not just the DC X
multiverse it's also it's the speedster
multiverse and the speedsters are the
ones who connect all of the disparate
pieces of it because Marvel is the
universe right it's just one world and
all the same characters in DC is a
multiverse all these different stories
with different realities different
characters and versions of characters
and the speedsters are the ones who move
through it all they're like the the
connecting bridge between all these
different collage parts and so I'm
really delighted at how focused everyone
is on getting it just right and I'm
really devoted to that as well and I
honestly like we won't make the film
unless it's going to be this consummate
beautiful offering to the to the fans
and to everybody I mean we're just gonna
make a fantastic food but we're really
focused on making it this like super
gift to DC fans
not as excited as me hey everybody its
charlie we got some really awesome news
about the flash movie with the story
that's going to be how it's gonna be
changing the DC Universe introducing the
multiverse I'll talk about that in a
second but also Warner Brothers
confirmed that they're going to be doing
another Superman movie
there will be more Man of Steel so we'll
break it down there's a new round of the
IMAX ticket giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your favorite Man of Steel or flash
moment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this I was actually
in the middle of making a totally
different DC video and all this news
just dropped it Ezra Miller just like
went on this big rant about what's going
on with the flash movie which is way
bigger in scope than I would have ever
expected in a post Justice League world
but the flash movie stuff and the
Superman stuff are tangentially
connected so we'll explain what people
are saying because this is all taken
from stuff that the Warner Brothers CEO
was talking about in addition to Ezra
Miller's comments about the flash movie
Warner Brothers CEO just did a big press
conference we talked about the future of
DC movies he addressed a lot of their
different franchises not just Batman and
Superman he was responding to a question
asking about what was finally clicking
about DC movies because now Aquaman
earned more money than the Dark Knight
it is now the highest grossing DC movie
in the history of Warner Brothers he
talks about their change in strategy
saying the upcoming slate with Shazam
Joker
Wonder Woman 1984 and birds of prey
feels like we're on the right track we
had the right people in the right jobs
working on it
the universe isn't as connected as we
thought it was going to be five years
ago you're seeing much more focus on
individual experiences around individual
characters that's not to say we won't at
some point come back to that notion of a
more connected universe talking about
future Justice League films but it feels
like that's the right strategy for us
now so also Aquaman relatively
self-contained even though they do
reference a lot of stuff during Justice
League think about movies going forward
before the next Justice League film
being like that where they reference
stuff that's happening in other movies
and present-day but you don't
necessarily see them all standing around
on screen together so then he goes on to
say what patty Jenkins did on Wonder
Woman Illustrated to us what you could
do with these characters who are not
Batman and Superman obviously we want to
get those two in a right place we want
strong movies around Batman and Superman
but Aquaman is a perfect example of what
you can do there
unique in the tones different in each
movie so that's him basically saying we
have big plans for Superman in the
future so of course it should go without
saying that they're always going to be
making Superman movies it's just a
question of when what the cast is going
to be what the story's going to be so if
you believe what Jason Momoa has been
saying recently he's been adamant
adamant that Henry Cavill is going to
come back and play Superman in order for
Henry Cavill to make it through a full
new Justice League trilogy because
that's so far often potentially new
Superman trilogy which I think he can
pull off but he'll be cutting it really
close he would actually have to go full
hugh jackman Patrick Stewart with the
length of time he plays that character
you may have seen the news recently
where Hugh Jackman and Patrick Stewart
are now tied in the Guinness Book of
World Records for longest run playing a
single character he was Wolverine and
Patrick Stewart Professor X for a full
16 years both of them starting in the
first x-men film so if Henry Cavill
debuted in 2013 is Superman that means
that we'd have to see all three new
Superman films and all three new Justice
League films by 2029 which surprisingly
does not leave a lot of time assuming it
takes up to two to three years between
movies so we'll circle back around to
that in a second because new Superman
stuff tied to all this flash stuff that
Ezra Miller is teasing and he teases
some really big stuff pretty funny to
see the way he addresses the delays he's
like yeah it's taking a really really
long time but he does offer a compelling
reason for why that is the scripts that
they have had under the other directors
there have been three so far that's part
of the joke is that there's so many
directors on the flash movie is they
just didn't feel like they were good
enough and they were going in a
direction that Warner Brothers wanted to
take all these characters so when he
says that they're sparking a whole new
universe with the story he's talking
both about introducing the idea of the
DC Multiverse
in the movies for the first time and
he's also talking about the world of the
flash characters so that would be any
character originating in the flash
comics like you see on the flash TV show
like Captain Cold the Rogues
Gorilla Grodd the other speedsters like
Jay Garrick Wally West Bart Allen
he literally references his version of
the flash connecting with other
speedsters of the multiverse on
different earths making the movie sound
way bigger in scope in terms of world
building for the movies but more
specific to the Canon of the flash
comics so like I said
Aquaman style where they're mostly
dealing with Flash characters but it's a
really big world building event for the
DC Universe of movies because you
introduced the multiverse he's a little
bit incorrect when he says that Marvel
is not a multiverse of characters but I
think he may just be referencing the
fact that most of Marvel's mainstream
comic book titles focus on the six one
six characters with a few exceptions
like Miles Morales the ultimate universe
of characters or like the spider-verse
titles like spider get in where you have
a multiverse of spider-man characters
interacting with each other when he says
that they're not gonna make the film
unless it's gonna be perfect I think
that's just Warner Brothers in the
producers themselves being very cautious
in a post Justice League Batman V
Superman world like they want to make a
film that pleases both the fans and the
critics which is almost impossible to do
but there are a lot of really easy slam
dunk story beats in the flash comics
that Ezra Miller mentions when he's
talking about what the flash movie is
going to do at least the current version
of the flash movie that they're making
he's effectively saying that the movie
is going to be a combination of
flashpoint story beats in the flash of
two worlds with either Jay Garrick or
Wally West or an alternate universe
version of his Barry Allen like he'd
interacting with himself from another
universe
that would be the simpler version of the
flash of two worlds if they don't want
to do Jay Garrick right away and they
want to tease him and Wally West and a
post-credits scene for future sequels
you don't have to be a genius to see
that they want to get to all those
really big speedsters from the flash
comics but you can't do that right away
like first you have to introduce the
brand new redesigned version of Ezra
Miller's flash like all this flashpoint
talk about changing the world is sort of
their way to soft reboot that character
so that means new flash suit the way
that he runs changes the way that
Central City looks is different some of
the actors might come back they haven't
said much about that Billy Crudup might
come back as Henry Allen Kirstie
Clements might come back as iris West
they haven't said much about those
supporting characters so that's still
wide open to theory crafting but because
Warner Brothers is waiting so long to do
that next Superman movie they want a
soft reboot most of their core just as
the characters Batman Superman Aquaman
was kind of a soft reboot ooh that
character posted Justice League I talked
about it a lot during my Aquaman review
about how James 1 just totally took that
character in a different direction than
what he was during Justice League so you
watched them
in both movies it almost feels like a
completely different character even
though it's still Jason Momoa both
versions control machine what we've
written it down first I memorized it
didn't you oh yeah what do you just say
something something tried it so what
they can do with this new flash
flashpoint multiverse movie is debut
either Henry cavils retuned version of
Superman or a totally new Superman if by
that time Henry Cavill really does want
to leave because we're talking like
flash movie might not make it around
till 2021 2022 at the earliest
henry cavill switcher series looks like
it's gonna take off and he may move on
to other franchises but if you believe
what Jason Momoa has been saying at his
recent appearances Henry Cavill
definitely plans to come back and I
posted a couple pictures every once in a
while because Henry Cavill is always
posing with Superman statues of himself
this is him working out in Bulgaria
while they're filming The Witcher so
he's still very clearly advertising
himself continuing to be Superman and
seems really jazzed up about the idea I
know they've been a lot of rumors behind
the scenes about Supergirl movies than
doing alternate reality versions of
Superman like Calvin Ellis as Michael B
Jordan that's what people are talking
about when they say that he would be a
version of Superman I think that's a lot
of talk I still think that Warner
Brothers is interested in Henry Cavill
continuing to be Superman in Henry
Cavill wants to continue playing the
character but the studio doesn't want to
make another movie until they feel like
they have a perfect script they probably
just don't feel like they've had any
pitches that they feel are compelling
enough at the moment and they're just
waiting for the perfect idea to come
along and at this rate it sounds like
it'll be quite a while but remember they
usually announced movies then maybe like
three years later we actually see the
movie unless you're the flash movie when
they announced it like a couple years
ago and it takes like five or six years
for them to make it so don't be
surprised if sometime by next year you
do hear rumblings of what that next
Superman movie is gonna be and then you
know cut to three years later we
actually see it on-screen
there was actually a video that I did
recently about their original trilogy
plans for Justice League which is really
bizarre Kevin Smith tells this really
long story about what Justice League was
originally going to be about the deleted
Green Lantern scenes during the movie so
we'll add a link to that at the end of
this
congratulations to RJ you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to learn about the
alternate Justice League trilogy Green
Lantern and all those deleted scenes and
click here for my brand new Shazam
trailer video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight